jaime's dad gave her a die for her
birthday she wanted to make sure it was
fair so she took her die to school and
rolled it 500 times and kept track of
how many times the die rolled each
number
afterwards she calculated the expected
value of the sum of 20 rolls to be
67.4
the expected value of the sum of 20
rolls to be 67.4
on her way home from school it was
raining and two values were washed away
from her data table
find the two missing absolute
frequencies from jamie's data table so
you see here she rolled her die 500
times and she wrote down how many times
she got a 2. she got a 210 times a 395
times a four seventy times a five
seventy five times and then she had
written down what she got how many times
she got a one and a six but then it got
washed away so we need to figure out how
many times she got a one and a six given
the information on this table right over
here and given the information that the
expected value of the sum of 20 rolls is
67.4 so i encourage you to pause this
video and think about it on your own
before i give a go at it
so first let's think about what what
this this expected value the sum of 20
rolls being 67.4 tells us that means
that the expected value of one roll the
expected the expected value of the sum
of 20 rolls is just 20 times the
expected value of one roll so the
expected value of a roll let me do it
here
expected
value
of a roll
is going to be equal to 67.4
divided by
20. we can get our calculator out
let's see
so we have 67.4
divided by
divided by 20 is 3.37
so this is equal to 3.37
so how does that help us
well we know how to calculate an
expected value given this this frequency
table right over here if we say that
this number right over here let's say
that's capital a
and let's say that this number here is
capital b
if we were to try to calculate the
expected value of a roll what we really
want to do is take the weighted
frequency of each of these values the
weighted sum so for example if we got a
1 a out of 500 times it would be a
out of 500
times 1
times 1
plus plus i'll do these in different
colors plus 110
out of 500 times 2
plus 110
out of 500
times 2. notice this is the frequency
which was they got 2 times 2 we're
taking a weighted we're taking a
weighted sum of these values
and then plus
95 out of 500 times 3
plus 95
out of 500 times 3
plus
i think you see where this is going 70
over 500 times 4
plus 70
over 500
times 4 almost there plus
let's see i haven't used this brown
color plus 75 over 500
times i'll do it here plus
75
over 500 times 5. finally plus
plus b over 500
plus b
over 500
times
times six this is going to give us our
expected value of a roll which is going
to be equal to 3.37
so all of this
all of this is equal to
is equal to 3.37
so one thing that we can do since we
have all these 500s in this denominator
right over here let's multiply both
sides of this equation times 500. if we
do that the left-hand side becomes well
500 times a over 500 is going to be a
plus 110
plus
100 and oh 110 times 2 so it's going to
be 220
plus 95 times 3 that's going to be 15
less than 300 so it's going to be plus
285
plus 2
85
and then 70 times 4 is 280
plus 280
75 times 5 is going to be 350 plus 25
375
so plus 375
plus
plus 6b
plus 6b
make sure i'm not skipping any steps
here plus 6b is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to this times 500
and that is going to be equal to 3.37
times 500
is equal to 16.85
1685. so all i did to go from this step
right over here to k
which i set up saying hey this is the
expected value of one roll which is
which we already know to be 3.37 is i
just multiplied both sides of this
equation by 500. i just did this times
500
and i did this times i did this times
500 and this 500 obviously cancels with
all of these and then 500 times 3.37 is
16.85 and so i got this right over here
now i got one two three four five six
yep i did i did enough i have the right
number of terms i just want to make sure
i'm not making a careless mistake and so
if we want to simplify this we can
subtract 220 285 280 and 375 from both
sides and so we would be if we did that
we would get a
if we subtract that from the left-hand
side we're going to get a plus 6b
a plus 6b and on the right hand side
we are going to get
let's get our calculator out
1685
minus
minus 220
220 minus 285
minus 285 minus 280
minus 280
minus 375
minus 375
gets us to
525
so we get
a
plus 6b is equal to
525 and you say okay you did all that
work but we still have one equation with
two unknowns how do we figure out what a
and b how do we figure out what a and b
actually are
well we know something else we know and
this was actually much easier to figure
out we know that the sum of this whole
table right over here a plus 1 10 plus
95 plus 70 plus 75 plus b is equal to
500
or if we let me write that down so we
know
we know that a
plus
plus
110 plus 95 plus 70
plus 75
plus b
plus b
needs to be equal to 500
needs to be equal to 500 or we could
subtract 110 plus 95 plus 70 plus 75
from both sides and get
if you subtract it from the left hand
side you're just left with a
plus b
a
plus b
and on the right hand side if we start
with
we start with 500 so 500
minus 110
minus 95
minus 70
minus 75
gets us to 150 so a plus b must be equal
to 150
is equal to
150.
and now we have a system of two
equations and two unknowns and so we
know how to solve those
we could do it by substitution or we
could subtract the second equation from
the first so let's let's do that let's
subtract the left-hand side of this
equation from that so or essentially we
could add these two we can multiply this
one times a negative one
and then add these two equations
the a's are going to cancel out and we
are going to be left with 6b minus b is
5b
is equal to 375
is equal to
375 did i do that right if i had 125 to
this i get to 500 then another 25 i get
to 525 so 5b is equal to 375 or if we
divide both sides by 5
we get b
is equal to
b is equal to 75.
b is equal to 75. so this right over
here is equal to 75
if b is equal to 75 what is a
well we know that a plus b is equal to
500 we figured that out a little while
ago before we multiplied both sides of
this times a negative one we knew that a
plus b
a plus b when b is now 75 so we could
say a plus 75
is equal to is equal to 150
is equal to 150
and that's just from from this we
figured out that a plus b is equal to
150 before we multiplied both sides
times a negative subtract 75 from both
sides you get a is also
equal to
75
and we are done